Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Hussein,
he Wasam.
[Silence]
Continuing in
the chapter of repentance
authored by Alawi,
he mentions in the 22nd narration
on the authority of Eban
Hussein ali may Allah be pleased with
him and his father. He narrates that a
woman from the tribe of Jua
came to the messenger of Allah Sall.
Wasam pregnant from adultery. She had
committed adultery and she was pregnant.
Pregnant from adultery.
And so she said, "Oh messenger of Allah,
I have
committed a crime worthy of punishment
and so establish the punishment,
the rightful punishment or judgment upon
me.
[Silence]
So he summoned
a man that was one of her guardians
or caretakers.
whether it's a brother or her father
or whoever it may be
and gave him instructions. The prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam said to him,
"Treat her well
and when she gives birth, come back
and inform me.
Wasam.
[Silence]
And so after she had given birth and
after she had suckled her child, her
newborn for two years until the child
was no longer in need of suckling and
was eating regular table food.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam then
commanded that the judgment of Allah
be established upon her. And so
her clothing was tightened
on her,
meaning she was tied in a way that would
keep her clothing on her body during for
the duration of the stoning
and she was then
the judgment of Allah Subhanahu
Waaala. was then established. We
understand from this that she was
married. She was not
single. She was a married woman who
had committed adultery.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam after she had completed after
the punishment was carried out he
sallall.aii wasallam made salat janza
upon her. He made salat janza upon her.
Salah janaza in especially for the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam was the
wish
of every single Muslim in the time of
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. The
greatest fear or one of the great fears
that they had was that they pass away
and the prophet sallall.aii wasallam not
make janza upon them. And so this was
used as a deterrent
to
illicit
behavior from the companions.
What does this mean? Meaning that a
person would fear that if he didn't pay
off his debt soon enough that maybe the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam wouldn't be
the one to make salat janza upon him.
Janza would be made it would be made
upon them. They're Muslim. However, the
thing was that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam makes salah janaza upon them.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
did not make janza upon certain
people who died committing
particular crimes or acts. Why? As a
deterrent. So for instance suicide he
sallallam
would not make janza upon a person who
had committed suicide.
as is in Muslim. Would Jan be made? Yes,
of course they are Muslim. Suicide is a
major sin in Islam. But they are Muslim.
They would be bathed and washed and
prepared
shrouded and they would make janza upon
them and they would bury the person. But
the fear was that the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam not make Janza
specifically him and so suicide was one
passing away without paying a person's
debts while having the ability to do so
right this was later abregated
in the later days of Medina and so
forth and so people would stay away from
particular
particularly heinous sins or crimes out
of fear that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam would not make janza upon them.
Is this something carried on after the
prophet meaning if there is someone who
is respectable in a community the
judge the scholar of a place to use this
as well as a deterrent? Yes. If people
understand it as a deterrent, if people
do not understand it as a deterrent,
then no.
Omar then asked, "Oh messenger of Allah,
you pray upon her
in spite of her adultery.
The prophet sallall.aii was responded,
"Indeed she has repented a repentance.
If it if it were to be divvied up and
divided among 70 of the people of
Medina, it would suffice 70 of them."
Her repentance was so earnest, her
repentance was so
concentrate, her repentance was so
potent that if she were to have that
same repentance divided among 70 of the
people of Medina, it would suffice them.
He said, "And is there anything more
virtuous than a person who gives himself
and his soul and his own life for the
[Arabic recitation]